de sarnaise une minute
si monsieur le Président nous ne sommes
pas dans des temps ordinaires et la
menace intérieure et extérieure elle est
réelle elle est bien là et c'est
pourquoi la volonté politique elle doit
s'exprimer vite l'Europe doit faire la
démonstration de sa capacité à agir dans
le cas naturel de son état de droit
évidemment qu'il faut améliorer le
partage des renseignements renforcer le
SIS renforcé europele mettre en oeuvre
un PNR européen intelligent de même il
faut décider de contrôler
systématiquement les frontières
aériennes maritimes terrestre de
Schengen pour montrer que oui Schengen
c'est efficace de même il faudra
renforcer euro juste et pourquoi pas
nous doter d'un procureur européen enfin
il nous faudra sur le long terme avoir
une stratégie réelle pour nos prisons
qui sont aujourd'hui trop souvent dans
nombre d'État membres une école pour le
crime et le terrorisme nous devrons
aussi mener une politique étrangère
responsable je pense en particulier à la
Turquie nous devons en collaboration
avec elle repenser pourquoi pas une
politique de visa temporaire enfin il
nous faudra avancer sur l'Europe de la
défense faisons tout cela ensemble alors
nous démontrerons que nous sommes enfin
à la hauteur des défis merci